I WANT TO GET MORE NOW TOP
STORY NOW.
UNBLOCKING UKRAINIAN GRAIN.
CAN A DEAL THAT COULD HELP FOOD
SUPPLY CHAINS WHICH ARE ALREADY
BATTERED BY A PANDEMIC.
IN THE LAST HOUR, MOSCOW AND
KYIV SIGNING A GREEN EXPORT
AGREEMENT, MEDIATED BY TURKEY
AND THE UNITED NATIONS.
IT WAS QUIET.
BUT IT WAS A MOMENTOUS ACT,
DESIGNED TO MOVE MILLIONS OF
TONS OF UKRAINIAN GRAIN TRAPPED
IN THE COUNTRY'S BLACK SEA
PORTS, BY RUSSIA'S INVASION.
THIS CORRIDOR SHOULD BE HUGELY
SIGNIFICANT IN ADDRESSING THE
GLOBAL FOOD SHORTAGE THAT WE
ARE SEEING TODAY.
I'M DELIGHTED TO SAY THAT THE
UN SECRETARY, GENERAL ONE OF
THE ARCHITECTS OF THIS DEAL,
AND TONYA TEARS, JOINS ME LIVE
FROM ISTANBUL.
SIR, IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON GETTING THIS
ACROSS THE LINE.
HOW LONG BEFORE THE SHIPMENTS
BEGIN, SIR?
>> I HOPE VERY SOON.
IN MY DISCUSSION WITH OUR
UKRAINIAN FRIENDS, HARBORS WILL
BE READY, TWO OF THEM, IN A FEW
DAYS AND I HOPE THE SHIPS CAN
GO IN, WE WILL BE ABLE, MAXIMUM
TWO WEEKS, TO START EXPORTING.
BUT THESE THINGS ARE ALWAYS
RELATIVELY COMPLEX, LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT THERE WILL NOT BE A
DE MINING.
SO THERE WILL BE SAFE CORRIDORS
MANAGED BY THE UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES COMBATTING THE
SHIPS TO THE HARBORS, AND WHEN
THEY ENTER OR WHEN THEY LEAVE
THEY WILL THEN ENTER INTO A
CORRIDOR WHOSE SAFETY AND
SECURITY IS GUARANTEED BY ALL
DEPARTMENTS.
>> THESE SHIPS CARRYING THE
GRAIN WILL HAVE TO NAVIGATE
MINEFIELDS, WHICH COULD PROVE
TO BE DIFFICULT OR HIGHLY
DANGEROUS.
CAN WE GET A BIT MORE DETAIL ON
HOW YOU PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THE
STEEL?
>> WELL, THE BANGS WERE PUT BY
THE UKRAINIANS, SO THEY KNOW
WHERE THE MINDS ARE.
AND THE IDEA THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE TO HAVE SAFE PASSAGES
THAT ALLOW SHIPS TO GO WITHOUT
ANY RISK.
BUT THE AGREEMENT ALSO
ESTABLISHES THAT IN CASE THE
ALLOWANCES THAT WILL NOW BE
MADE WILL DETECT SOME
IMPROVEMENTS WHICH NEED TO BE
MADE.
THERE IS AN AGREEMENT FOR
ANOTHER COUNTRY TO BE INVOLVED
IN THE QUID THE MINING
OPERATION, WHEREVER NECESSARY.
BUT WE HOPE IT WILL NOT BE
NECESSARY IN THOSE SAFE
PASSAGES IN THE UKRAINIAN
WATERS LEWIS NOT FORGET THAT IN
THESE UKRAINIAN WATERS THE
SHIRTS WILL BE CONDUCTED BY
UKRAINIAN PILOTS AND SUPPORTED
BY UKRAINIAN POSTCARDS.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT THIS
DEAL WILL STICK, PARTICULARLY
FROM THE RUSSIAN SIDE?
DO YOU TRUST THEM?
>> WELL, NOBODY BELIEVED WHEN I
SAID THREE MONTHS AGO THAT I
HAD MADE THIS PROPOSAL TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN INTO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, AND THAT WE WERE
STARTING TO WORK ON IT.
EVERYBODY WILL SAY THIS WAS NOT
POSSIBLE IT HAS HAPPENED.
SO I BELIEVE IT IS IN THE
MUTUAL INTEREST OF THE PARTIES
BECAUSE THESE WILL REPRESENT
NOT ONLY AN IMPORTANCE SOLUTION
FOR UKRAINE THAT HAS ALL OF THE
SILOS OF FOOD, AND THE NEW
HARVEST BEING MADE.
SO IT IS VITAL TO EXPORT
UKRAINIAN GRAINS.
BUT WE ARE WORKING ALSO, AS IT
IS KNOWN, WITH THE U.S. IN THE
EU.
THEY'VE ALSO ALREADY ISSUED A
STATEMENT IN RELATION TO THIS,
THERE IS NO SANCTIONS ON
PUTIN'S ABSURD LIES ARE FOR THE
LIES, OR RUSSIAN FERTILIZER.
SO IT WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS WORLD MARKETS.
AND THESE TWO COMBINED
OPERATIONS WILL BE A HUGE
INJECTION THAT I BELIEVE WILL
BRING PRICES DOWN AND STABILIZE
THE MARKETS, AND WILL ALLOW
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES IN AN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT SITUATION
IN VULNERABLE SITUATIONS WHERE
FAMILY IS GROWING, IT WILL
ALLOW THIS TO STOP.
THAT WAS OUR OBJECTIVE, OUR
MOTIVATION.
WHAT IS GUIDED US DURING THESE
THREE MONTHS, THERE WERE MANY
DIFFICULT OBSTACLES, BUT I HAVE
TO SAY THAT TODAY I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT DAY OF MY TENURE
SECRETARY GENERAL.
>> IS THERE A MECHANISM IN
PLACE TO HOLD PARTIES
ACCOUNTABLE SHOULD THEY RENEGED
ON THIS DEAL, SO?
>> THERE IS A JOINT
COORDINATION, JOINT
COORDINATION COMMITTEE'S
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE UN
TURKEY RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
ALL MOVEMENTS WILL BE A BY THIS
COMMITTEE ALL SHIPS THAT WILL
BE IN THIS MOVEMENT WILL BE
REGISTERED AND WILL BE FOLLOWED
THROUGH REMOTE RECONNAISSANCE
MECHANISMS IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL KNOW ANTHONY
MOVEMENT OR ANY VOTE OR
SHEEP'S.
AND THERE IS A CLEAR COMMITMENT
OF DEPARTMENTS THAT NOT ONLY
KNOW ATTACKS WILL BE MADE ANY
OF THESE SHIPS, BUT THAT THE
CONTROL WILL BE REMOTE NOT TO
HAVE MORE SHIPS IN THE
PROXIMITY.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
NOW A CLEAR MECHANISM TO, IF
THERE IS ANYTHING WRONG, IF
THERE IS AN INFECTION, TO MAKE
THE COMPANY VERY EASY TO
ESTABLISH.
>> LAST MONTH YOU MARKED A GRIM
MILESTONE OF 100 DAYS OF WAR TO
RENEW A CALL FOR AN IMMEDIATE
END TO THIS VIOLENCE.
MORE THAN A MONTH ON, WITH NO
END IN SIGHT, DO YOU ACCEPT THE
CRITICISM OF THE UN'S FAILURE
TO HALT MOSCOW'S AGGRESSION?
>> WELL, I DO NOT THINK IT IS A
FAILURE OF THE SECRETARY OF THE
UN, IF THERE IS A FAILURE IT IS
IN THE SECURITY COSTS WHICH OF
COURSE THE RUSSIAN --
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR ANY DECISION
TO STOP THE WAR AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE UN CHARTER OF THE
NATIONAL LAW IS RESPECTED.
BUT I THINK YOU AND HAS BEEN
DOING AN EXTRAORDINARY WORK
FROM THE HUMANITARIAN POINT OF
VIEW, WE ALREADY HAVE TWO
INTERACTIONS AND WHICH ARE
MEDIATIONS, THE SECOND ONE
TOGETHER WITH TURKEY, THE FIRST
WAS THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THE CIVILIANS FROM HOSTILE,
WHICH FOR MONTHS WAS
CONSIDERING ITSELF POSSIBLE
UNTIL WE GOT INVOLVED.
AND NOW DISAGREEMENTS.
SO I BELIEVE THE UN IS DOING A
LOT.
BUT ONE THING IS CLEAR, WE ARE
FAR FROM A DISAGREEMENT.
I HAVE SOME MIXED FEELINGS.
ON THE ONE HAND I MUST SAY THAT
I AM HAPPY BECAUSE I THOUGHT
ONCE WE WANTED.
ON THE OTHER HAND IT IS JUST
WHEN YOU SEE THAT THE WAR IS
RAGING, THAT UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING, AND OBVIOUSLY I
CAN ONLY HOPE THAT THE BACK
SEAT WILL ALLOW US TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO A ROAD TO
PEACE, A ROAD TO PEACE WHICH IS
ALWAYS IN RESPECT OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
>> AND YOU HAVE DESCRIBED TWO
DAYS AGREEMENT AS A BEACON OF
LIGHT, A BEACON OF HOPE IN THE
BLACK SEA.
THE SYMBOLISM OF SEEING THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS AT THE
SAME TABLE, CERTAINLY, IS ONE
THAT OUGHT TO PROVIDE SOME
OPTIMISM IN WHAT IS SUCH A GRIM
SITUATION.
RUSSIA'S PERMANENT MEMBERSHIP
OF THE UN SECURITY COUNCIL DOES,
EFFECTIVELY, WE'RE INTO THAT
BODY IN EFFECT EVENT PRESIDENT.
THAT MUST BE A CONCERN TO YOU,
ISN'T IT?
>> WELL, MY MESSAGE IS VERY
CLEAR.
THAT IS ALL BEING INSPIRED BY
WHAT WAS A SHIFT.
LET US BE CONSCIOUS THAT WE ARE
VERY FAR FROM A SITUATION IN
WHICH A GROUP OF PROCESS IS
POSSIBLE.
BUT LET'S DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO CREATE THE CONDITIONS
FOR IT TO HAPPEN.
BUT I REPEAT, WITH RESPECT TO
THE UN CHARTER AN INTERNATIONAL
LAW.
>> YOUR WORK IS TIRELESS'S,
SIR.
YOU DESERVE CONGRATULATIONS FOR
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE BEHIND
THE SCENES TO HELP BROKER THE
DEAL TODAY.
YOU EXPLAINED, AS TO THE
TURKISH PRESIDENT, THAT THIS IS
MONTHS IN THE MAKING.
IT IS REALLY GOOD NEWS THAT WE
SEE THIS DEAL ANNOUNCED TODAY,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT, BUT AS
YOU RIGHTLY POINT OUT WE NEED
TO SEE THE END TO THIS WAR.
>> IF I MAY THERE IS ONE THING
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
IN THIS WORLD IN WHICH
EVERYBODY NOW BASICALLY TALKING
TO THE MEDIA, BEFORE TRYING TO
DO ANYTHING, I THINK THIS HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE IS
STILL A ROAD FOR DISCREET
DIPLOMACY IN THE WORLD.
THERE IS STILL A ROAD FOR
PEOPLE SEEKING THE SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEMS AND NOT SEEKING
THE --
IN THE MEDIA THAT LASTS FOR A
FEW HOURS BUT HAS NO IMPACT ON
THE REMNANTS OF THE SEA.
>> YOU MAKE A GOOD, POINT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING.